hi
good morning everyone
i'm happy and honored to give you uh to
give this introductory session on
reparations
uh but before i start i would like to uh
give you my disciplinary perspective
uh
the the concept of reparations uh the
concept of reparation has been studied
from different uh angles
uh indeed in different disciplines uh
whether it's economy uh sociology law uh
philosophy and um i would like to uh uh
to give you more details from where i
i
speak that i stand when i uh talk about
this concept of reparation
so uh during my phd dissertation
i studied uh mobilization of apartheid
victims uh in south africa before
american goods and south african courts
and within this uh dissertation i
treated the question of
of reparations how this concept was
appropriated and used by
um
victims movements
ngos
lawyers
and different group of actors
so i'm not uh
and after that
uh i work for different ngos in
human rights
um organizations mainly in sub-saharan
africa uh organizations which were which
were implementing
uh
uh programs of reparations
um
and at this age i'm not uh i'm not going
i'm not going to give you a uh
a presentation on the meaning of the
concept of reparations but rather on
uh how this concept is uh used
appropriated in different contexts by
different actors
um
and what are the conclu the concrete
implications of this
uh of this multiple
uh
multiple uh
users
i'm gonna uh i'm gonna share my screen
with you um i think will be more helpful
since i have different uh concrete
examples
this
um
okay
so
we we have we have
i know you have just read the text of uh
written by pablo de grace on the concept
of reparations and on the meaning of on
the and on the distinction between
different contexts where the term of
expression is is used
uh in his uh text
pablo de grace makes a distinction
between
international law
where the concept of reparation can take
different forms
he talks about restitution compensation
rehabilitation satisfaction and
guarantee of non-reputation
the other context in which the term
regression is frankly frequently used
according to a pablo regret
is the design of
of programs
of reparation programs with massive
coverage
[Music]
and here
he insists on the difference between
these different contexts
and
explaining how
one
uh in the in context of international
law uh the concept of recreation has a
kind of juridical uh meaning
uh whereas in the second one it's uh
the reparations are are apprehended much
more as a political project
and i would like to um to uh to stop on
this point to share or to illustrate
uh uh
the how these distinctions or how
different appropriation of the concept
of operation plays uh
uh play out in the in the in a concrete
case
which is uh the case of apartheid uh
victims mobilization in south africa
i would start by this by this uh example
of uh our project victims mobilization
so um as you know um
the at the end of apartheid
uh the saga the south african government
set up a truth and reconciliation
commission in charge of telling the
truth of the crimes of apartheid grant
amnesty if certain conditions were made
and proposing recommendations for
reparations
uh the image and the on the left
uh
illustrate one of the session the truth
and reconciliation commissions this so
this commission was
uh
was held between
1996 and 1998 some of the work continued
after but the main sessions were held
during that time
um
and the the south african truth and
reconciliation commission
uh which uh interpreted uh interpreted
approached violence
as a human as human rights violations
related to physical and
integrity
and as observed by uh mahmoud mandani
and many other scholars after
uh this narrow interpretation of
apartheid violence has the consequences
and has the consequence of putting aside
or uh the structural character of our
parted injustices
uh of
not considering the social economic
violence of the of the party system and
uh and at the level of reparations
uh this has a consequence since
uh there's only a limited number of um
of people
uh that were considered as victims of
apartheid
that have that have been given the
status of victim apartheid it's only 22
000 people who could benefit from
individual reparations
this the small nuance that uh uh uh i
could bring on i can bring on this
aspect is that in the um
the the trc the truth and reconciliation
commission discourse uh
was aware that um
of course apartheid uh
involved much more discriminations but
people who have been given the status of
victims and who could have access to
reparations
or were only 22 000
um
in in the early 2000s
uh in the early 2000s a group of victims
of apartheid victims decided to go to
court uh to court uh before american
quotes and that's in the image that we
have on the
uh on the right side
they went to court and they sued
multinational uh corporations uh
that were accused of having
aided and abated the apartheid
regime in this trial
the victims challenged the concept of
reparations
um that was based on the physical
violence on a physical integrity and
they are
one of the main arguments was to say
that uh entire communities were affected
by apartheid
uh a system of discrimination
uh
a product can't constitute a system of
of discriminations that affected every
aspect of of the existence of
black populations from most intimate
uh relations with whom you could marry
to the places where you study where you
could work where you can travel where
you can live so this structural
character of apartheid
uh and consequently
the reparations cannot be individuals
cannot be uh apprehended on the uh at
the individual basis they must take into
account this structural dimension
um
so this lawsuit has uh has been uh
has been brought into court in uh
uh
uh in 2002
um
and um
and it and stayed in court until
uh thousand 2015
but um
but um
it couldn't go further because of the
legal proceedings and all the challenges
of bringing
a south african case facts before
american courts
we could go further uh
into further details uh
later on uh but i'm i'm going to limit
myself
here on this question on this aspect
but uh what is important here to uh to
keep in mind or to uh
on this aspect of preparations it's
first of all it is um
this case illustrates how it is
important to pay attention
uh on the concept
uh how the concept of reparation is
approached and appropriated by different
actors whether it's state actors but we
look also how people uh
uh how movements uh ngos uh victims uh
can
formulate and reformulate demands uh on
and negotiating and negotiate the sense
of reparations
so
all this all that to say that the the
meaning of preparation is not something
that is fixed that is rigid is something
that evolves and that is uh that can be
uh that that evolves over time and over
space as we see here for what what what
happens in the south africa and how it
goes into american words
and uh
um
that is contested
um
the second element that um uh
that this case uh
highlights is that
uh
if we if we understand the concept rep
uh the concept of uh reparation as it
has been defined by the truth and
reconciliation commission uh and we will
compare it to how it is defined by
victims movements in the case of uh
uh when they go into america to american
courts we can see that these these
there are concrete implications there
are significant concrete implications
uh because in one case we have 22 000
people who have access to reparations
uh whereas in the second case uh their
argument
uh was to say if we have if we take into
account the multiplicity of
discrimination that uh that were
inherent for to the system of apartheid
then we have to reconsider the number of
people who have uh who are victims and
who have access to reparations
uh so um
we can see that behind this uh
may be abstract definition
there is a significant differences and
concrete uh
concrete stakes that are important i
would like to move to the
um uh
to a second case uh which is
uh
the link
uh a second case but which highlight
likes the importance of
uh
the significance of the link between the
qualification of violence and
reparations
um
in other words what kind of balance can
be repaired
uh
and
what can balance and can be repaired
what kind of
victims have access to our two
reparations
um
the most significant or the most telling
case in this regard for me concerns uh
the demand for reparations uh expressed
by namibia and uh or
over here nama and sun communities to
germany
uh
reparations of demand for repression
that have been which have been expressed
um
concerning the genocide against those
populations at the end at the beginning
of the 20th century
uh the the process of planning this
reparation began in 2005 with interested
uh
discussions between germany and namibia
and for a very long time
uh germany
uh
but also all the former colonial powers
have been advancing the inter-temporal
principle
so this is a principle
in international law which stresses that
a state is
responsible for violation of
international law only if at the time of
the violation or of its continuing
effects
the state was bound by the legal
provision it transgressed
so in other words
uh and this is the argument which has
been given by uh
uh by by germany
uh
they at the time of uh
at the time
uh the genocide was committed they were
not uh they're not they were not
violating any international law uh and
therefore there's no obligation
uh to provide reparations
uh this argument has been used by uh has
been used uh by germany uh and
and is still
and somehow still uh being used by uh
germany
but it also um
[Music]
it has been also being used by uh by
many formal colonial powers
uh
as here you can see the um
the image here at the durban conference
which is uh the conference the one of
the biggest conference on uh
on
[Music]
organized by the united nations in 2001
20 years ago um
on racism
and uh when many
states expressed the need for
reparations uh within this conference
the respond uh the response sorry of uh
of uh many colonial former colonial
powers was to say
uh
to advance this principle
however
um
some
scholars and i think that is also the
case for the un's uh the u1 special
rapporteur on a
question of reparations
uh it is to say that there is an
exception
and there is an exception if um if
direct consequences
of uh of these acts
extend into a time when the act and its
consequences are considered
international wrongful
so for example that means that we could
not use
this for them in their interpretation we
cannot use this principle uh for racial
discriminations
now because they are the consequences of
uh um
of these facts that happen at a time uh
where state had no
legal international legal obligation
because we still we we have direct
direct ongoing consequences of this of
this fact
uh
this case uh for me
this case for me uh is uh
it's
it's illustrative of a different
different
important significant points
the first and the first point that i
want to insist upon is that
the moment when the facts happen uh the
fact of which people are asking or
reparations or reparation claims are
made
that moment is fundamental since it
determines
whether state can be liable on the basis
of international law and us reparations
this is the first uh
uh
key
element the second element
uh what this case is illustrative uh of
is the
the paradox
uh faced by reparations uh movements
since in order to demand uh
the
the paradox that they have to use uh
tools international if they use
international law uh they are
constrained to uh
uh
to a legal system
uh
and we and with its limits and principle
which has rendered possible uh the
colonial system so they have to
operate in a system that was
uh that was at the basis of a colonial
uh
phenomenon
and uh to challenge
the the to challenge that system on the
basis of uh the legal system is quite
constraining and imposes of the
of the
number of limits
um and this leads me to my uh the third
uh point that i would like to uh and the
third and last point that i would like
to to share with you
uh
or
i will even say questions so if we think
that uh
international law is uh
is limiting
uh because of certain principles that
have been set up at a moment where
colonialism was
[Music]
was
prospering
if we if we think that it's limiting
then what kind of modern justice should
we use who could we use if we want to
ask for preparation what could be the
alternative to repo to our international
law
um
and um
one of uh
one of the the the case that could be uh
that is interesting what uh
uh here as um
is um
is the canadian is uh the
the case of
of reparations uh in in canada
so
uh before i uh before i address the
image and the the
situation that you see here i would like
to uh just give you a little bit a
little bit of background um
so as you may know in the from the late
uh
19th century to 1996 uh the government
of canada operated uh the indian
residential school system with the goal
of assimilating indigenous children by
indigenous children by stripping them
with traditions customs
values languages
uh the children's were subjected to
different
uh to different physical abuses uh
sexual and uh
and uh emotional
abuses
and in the early nineties uh former
students of this system decided to
litigate um
uh to ask for report uh
to rep to ask for reparations
uh
to the to the government but also to the
churches that were involved in in this
system
and they uh they launched um in
a lawsuit and this lawsuit led to a
a settlement with a with a with a
government
a settlement of five billion
uh donors
um
uh and uh that settlement also involved
reparations uh
reparations which were not found not
only
not on uh not not only financial
reparations but also
the acknowledgement of the past wrongs
compensation rehabilitative measures uh
including
uh physical and psycho psychological
health services legal services educate
educational support
and the establishment of the truth and
reconciliation commission
and uh
the chief investigator
involved in this uh in the negotiation
of this settlement
i has explained
uh that it was possible that settlement
was only possible
uh by setting aside a
conventional liberal
legal frameworks
of third and civil law in favor of
indigenous law and legal traditions
and my point here
is
is that
um is to to show what is the what is the
uh what can be achieved if we
you know
we can be achieved if we decide of if we
should follow
alternative paths to our international
law
and uh for me
and this is
more a question and i think something
that will address in the different
uh in the different uh
uh
workshops or
the different presentations that are
that will follow uh
in the modules is to understand what
extent that uh
the the transitional justice framework
could be useful
uh in addressing
uh responding or
colonial
addressing colonial violence's
injustices colonial and but also slave
why do i uh
why do i bring this question of
transitional uh justice framework um
i i think i um
i think about transitional justice
framework because
um
the the original idea behind
transitional justice
is that
legal practitioner and that's in the
late uh late 90s uh some legal
practitioners
uh
ha uh expressed the need uh to
question the centrality of the criminal
trial as a way to respond to a mass
violence
and the there was a desire among these
legal practitioners to uh to look at the
mechanisms that were used in different
in a
uh
mechanism for resolving conflicts in the
african states uh in uh
in some
uh
in asian state uh south america but
non-western
non-western concept of
of
of seeking individual responsibility
and they were uh
and they they
and within this interrogation emerged
idea of uh using some concept and
mechanisms truth and reconciliation
commission
of course uh that was the the original i
uh original id in the
in the
uh in the 80s but after that
the transitional justice feed work has
evolved and has
come to include um
criminal uh
criminal trials
uh i'm not here to say if it's a it's a
a good uh
i mean it's a
uh
a good or bad evolution but uh
i uh we know that the the feed has
evolved and has come to include this
evolution
um and has come to be much more uh
it's much more
uh used by international organizations
ngo united nations with all the
technicalities it involves but at the uh
at the beginning of this interrogation
there was the need to uh to
to question the centrality or the the
western use of of trials
and um and um
yeah what i found it what i found it uh
uh
interesting in this uh in this debates
about reparation and about
reparations for colonialism is to
to see
if these models that are
most of the time used in the in the in
the global south if they can be used to
rethink the way we think about tribes uh
we think about
litigation
regarding colonialism and slavery
[Music]
in the in the western societies
um
so all these to say that it's uh the
concept of reparation is not uh
is uh
is uh
it's it's not something
it's not i mean to conclude it's not
something that is a that is uh rigid
rigid it's not something that has a
fixed meaning it's something that is is
evolving over time and over space but it
is also a concept that is evolving in
the midst of
many uh transformations of international
law of transitional justice of other uh
of other mechanisms and practices that
are
uh
also inherited from
uh
from the
the history of the legal cis uh legal
systems and uh uh
uh and practices of resolving conflicts
yes so
that's it uh let's
uh
we can yeah we can we can uh
i think that we can
um
dig
or we can go deeper into some
aspects within the
q a
and of course within the modules
thank you
you